[Music]
both successful comedians if you had bad
shows in the past shows we just couldn't
make it work yeah a lot one-one was
violent for me I was opening up for my
friends band called man man and I was
doing a joke about wrestling and Hulk
Hogan and some guy who looked like a
wrestler he looked like the wrestler
tugboat ran onto stage and picked me up
and then body slam me and then I thought
that was the worst that could happen and
then he pulled down his sweatpants and
it just tried to sit on my face like
underwear no do you wear underwear with
sweatpants this guy didn't and he tries
to start and no one's helping me so I
grab a mic stand I got knocked over and
I'm holding it up like this which is
cheeks then collapse around oh my and
it's so close to my face and I'm
screaming and it's why is he doing I
mean so he I don't know okay cuz because
I'm really funny and that was the way he
showed love as a wrestler it's the only
way he knows how
there's no security there's no one there
did anyone try to help here no no one
tried to help me there was one girl who
took my shoe my foot was at the edge of
stage some girl took my shoe and then
afterwards was like why didn't anybody
help me they're like I thought you knew
him and so I someone found it at the
bottom of a garbage can yeah without the
laces and then I was walking down the
street in New York trying to find a
place where I can buy some shoelaces and
then I saw the guy coming up to me I got
really scared and he walked up to me
he's all that was great they really
hated me it was like a wrestling match
he does that when he just he just loves
to participate when he's watching comics
perform I think so I think he's just all
about showbiz yeah I like the idea of
someone who's at a comedy show and
someone sitting on their face and
they're like why needed to buy shoelaces
I think I could just get bad guys
shoo-shoo the perfect crime I had this
one I was in Chicago and I had a show at
a gay bar and there was gay porn playing
everyone I didn't know it was a gay bar
hold it it was called jackhammer I went
to a club called jackhammer and you
didn't know it was a gay bar I think it
was like for construction workers yeah I
was like that's why they're all
shirtless you know they're hard day of
laying down the blacktop the picture
outside with the naked guy just with the
jackhammer so many clues Conan but I'm
in there and there was gay porn playing
at while I'm performing should have been
the other clue by the time I saw the gay
porn I was pretty sure I knew what I was
dealing with right but it was very
distressed and I've never seen gay porn
it's not my thing
it was very distracting for everybody
but it's also distracting for me because
I'm not into gay porn but these guys are
the best at it you know these are like
professionals like I don't love juggling
but if someone's like these are
award-winning jugglers I'm gonna be like
I'll give him 40 seconds see what her
I'd imagine
like they're doing things that never
seen before they're very good at what
they do they're the best at what they do
yeah so you so so you were distracted
and you found yourself not doing the act
and just watching the no I'd repeat for
a while I did my act but every now and
then I would look at like cuz because
the the thing is I'm not into juggling
but everyone else at the bar that we
really love juggling so their variant I
bombed didn't do well and the next day
the Booker called me was like that was
great you want to come back and do it
again I was like no I'm never coming
back if you don't go back you're
homophobic you should go back I've
messed up